so it's Monday it is it's Monday and
it's the beginning of a new week new we
can you pop what are you doing oh no
who's attacking the damn side of this
chair she said come on daddy play and
she wants me to go in the other room and
wrestle dad to [ __ ] wrestle on the
rug you like to wrestle on the rug no
yeah she does okay and also she likes to
play in the closet yeah she waits for
you when you get out of the shower yeah
and then when you get out of the shower
she runs past into the closet she goes
boom yeah makes all kinds of noise and
there's rolling around look at you
poking so what's all this Jenny what we
got to talk about not a lot what have
you been up to today Ivan
I've been working on the CD cover that I
was researching a Mexican food with Jay
ear
I was watching this guy maybe we'll put
a link or something he was going through
going through Mexico Tijuana Mexico City
sampling all the street food I was
watching how they were making it where
they do stuff is basically why I do it
and you know I evolved independently to
come up with the same solutions they did
yeah but I saw some [ __ ] that they were
doing man I was like man it's a good
idea it fried tortilla about a corn
tortilla about half way and pull it back
out and then throw it into something
like oil that had been soaked in red
chili yeah and then they might throw it
into like pork drippings to get pork
juice in it and then put it back in
there and fry it again so it would come
out pork flavored thanks and they're
doing stuff like stacking to quarantine
tortillas on top of one another and
putting some so much filling in there it
doesn't really fold over it's just lb
bagging it's like a damn comb it's like
a ice cream cone no you know instead of
lettuce they're using cabbage like I use
you know they came up a lot of same
solutions I did but man I didn't know it
but there's a Middle Eastern influence
in too
those yeah yeah they had some Lebanese
people go down there a long time ago you
know like this net lamb rotisserie lamb
but yeah we call that it's like for
making you toes yeah yeah well they're
taking a whole bunch of pork seasoned
pork and putting them on them and
putting it in a rotisserie and then they
just take a flour tortilla and slice it
off in there and in had pineapple up
there and put that in it and then yeah
make make tacos like this it looks good
really good every time we do this we're
gonna be so fat by the time we finish
doing this [ __ ] cookbook I was
watching these uh Mexican Indian women
in their little farm make Moyo and man
they were putting a lot of work into
that that was kind of like they put as
much work just into that damn Moyer
sauce boy I mean sauce salsa it put so
much work into that it was like
Thanksgiving they're grinding everything
by hand on those damn Mayan grinders
yeah the you know the lime stone
grinding tools you know looks like a
damn looks like a little stone table
with a like a stone roller yeah like a
stone rolling pin and their raw bacon
chiles and grind them in there and all
different kinds of spices them the more
you actually which I made now made some
today but I had pre-made Moyo
it's kind of like the Mexican Indian
version of damn chili not chili excuse
me uh curry yeah you know chicken rice
and in that Moyo
it's got it's a chocolaty Moyo good yeah
it is actually really good that's how I
didn't know what you were making in
there and then I thought when you
brought it in I was kind of like oh you
must have got ideas from all those like
Mexico Mexican food you're a research
yeah was thing is in the cookbook I
think I'm gonna put a recipe for boyo to
make it yeah cuz you wouldnt be able to
get that in Europe I don't think not
pre-made and the pre-made stuff is not
gonna be anywhere as good as what you
could make yeah I mean we've had several
different kinds of pre-made Moyo that
that was actually pretty good is okay
yeah yeah but making it you know the way
I was seeing these women make it man it
was it looked fantastic it looked like
better than II korma yeah or any curry
and you know the British they like
curries well this is like a Mexican
curry yeah I got like an Aztec curry and
this shit's old man they've been doing
it for hundreds of years this goes back
to Aztec days yeah you know well some of
this but it's weird because some of the
spices in Mexican food and Indian food
are similar yeah some of it yeah a lot
of that had to do those because you know
Mexico became part of the the Spanish
Empire yeah and it's but a long time ago
that started you know in the 1500s yeah
and because of that Mexico started to
get access to spices throughout the
empire yeah so a lot of it wasn't
indigenous originally indigenous to
Mexico it got adopted but they knew what
to do with it well yeah yeah you know
has taken mined Mesoamerican societies
were far more advanced than you know
European people of European heritage
imagine when when Cortes and his men
first saw Mayan and Aztec cities they
were just [ __ ] astounded they're
bigger than anything in Europe in those
days they were brightly painted in
turquoise and red and you know they had
in the centralized planning lots of
statues and temples and a lot of
organization it was a high culture
you're talking about something that's
like on par with feudal Japan or maybe
you know Imperial China you know it was
it was advanced but it they were all so
[ __ ] wild man taken taken
hallucinogenic drugs weird-ass religious
rites that involved human sacrifice
child sacrificed cannibalism you know
they did all that ritual kind of like
ritual slavery and murder it was all
made sense though within the context of
the Mesoamerican religion religion
though you know it was all rationalized
you had to do it the blood debt you had
to pay the blood debt back to keep the
Sun going yeah it was what would happen
cuz
the world would end exactly and you as a
soldier and you go out you know your job
as a soldier no matter what city state
you were in your job was to go capture
warriors a lot of times in even there
were even ball games involved where the
losers were sacrificed yes
but you know you had to capture got
other soldiers and then take them back
to your city and sacrifice them to pay
back the blood debt well those captured
soldiers win Allah willing we walked up
to the top of the damn temple it was
their duty you know it was their
religious duty as part of the soldier to
to pay back the blood debt so you know
so God wouldn't destroy the earth yeah
you know it made sense in that context
but you know if you actually look into
all what happened in the history of
Mexico you know the the Spaniards
[ __ ] the Spaniards were [ __ ]
terrified of what they saw that was a
[ __ ] you know then their guns and
cannons really didn't help the Cortes
Cortes helped topple the Aztec empire
with the help of you know basically
millions of Indian allies from other
cities yeah you know he did you know it
wasn't done by you know 200 Spaniards
that's not really how it was just they
probably told people that's what they
the only 200 of us men were such big
yeah that was you know that was Spanish
propaganda that 200 Spaniards with some
[ __ ]
with arquebus which is damn [ __ ]
matchlock rifles which were [ __ ]
useless really that that they toppled
the Empire now they did it with [ __ ]
allies and politics and mind control and
deception I had a lot to do with it and
religion they used the Aztec religion
against the Aztecs a lot because they
thought it was Kukulcan that's part of
it you know and Kukulcan has described
as a European that came and taught them
everything about civilization and at the
Mayan and the the the Aztecs and the
Mayans but the Aztec nobility believed
that they had to
send it from kugel Khan you know they
told Cortez that they weren't from
Mexico that they were from Europe
basically and I can even show you the
quote so I people don't know that which
it may have been that whoever went there
a long time ago they might have been
Greeks or something that because it
predated it predated the Aztec empire by
probably a thousand years they're
talking about a long long time ago maybe
the BC period whoever it was a lot of
them may have stayed behind and it
wasn't one man it must have been a whole
ship load of them and maybe they just
bred it in with the population so you
know I mean yeah all the nobles thought
they were from somewhere else and they
said it was from the West across the
ocean so they must be talking about
Europe and you know what's-his-name
granham Graham Hancock talked about that
may have been it might have been
something like a Phoenician trading
vessel or something Greek you know that
they left the Mediterranean and got
blown off-course and you know
accidentally showed up you know on the
coast of South Central America somewhere
it probably wasn't Mexico you know I
mean it was probably somewhere around
Brazil or maybe maybe Venezuela you know
a long time before the Mexicans or
wherever a router that or the the Aztecs
wherever around is weird
there was also a lot of evidence that
black people were there the Olmec
statues look like black people and off
the coast of Chile was Easter Island and
they were described as black people with
blonde hair yeah so you had like people
don't realize it but you know black
people were soso seafaring thousands of
years ago they went down through
Micronesia you know all through the
little island chains Australia and
evidently South America that but they
all mixed in waves and waves of
immigration into the American continent
that's that's you know it's always been
that this continents always been
basically invaded by people over and
over and over again going
prior maybe not maybe not even on
purpose walking across the ice sheets
from me from Europe walking across land
bridges from China being blowed of being
blown ashore you know because you were
Polynesian trying to get to the other
Island but the [ __ ] wind blew you up
for God and up in him she lay or
something you know as I live here now
yeah I'm here now and the same thing was
happening to black Africans you know
they were showing up here thousands
years ago cuz they were they were
seafaring also but we're so far back we
don't know what kind of boats you know
yeah I know I feel like there was so
many like sea voyages that yeah yeah
I've been lost a time because I you know
I guess later on it was just kind of
like yeah they didn't really start that
till later but I kind of think that's
[ __ ] I know you know yes it's long
distance isn't [ __ ] but it's not as long
as you think yeah okay you like if the
weather conditions are right you can get
from the Americans from the New World to
Europe in a few weeks that's not that
far yeah like three weeks they had a
they had an Indian guy or a Native
American guy who got captured by British
sailors and they took him back to
England and you know and they basically
showed him off to the Royal people and
was going to you know spending going to
parties and palaces and [ __ ] like that
and eventually the Royal people got kind
of bored of him and just told me to get
the [ __ ] out so then he spent most his
time in a damn bar speak English and
everything and this was I think back in
the 1600s and he could speak English and
everything and he said [ __ ] I'm going
back home he got into a damn little
bitty dingy sailboat I had a whole bunch
of food and water and went back to
America yeah hello yeah in a [ __ ]
little bitty sale we really wanted to
get [ __ ] that was 1600s yeah um they
knew I mean they knew what they were
doing they do what they were doing they
we're not stupid no not by any stretch
of the imagination
you just had balls yeah because
that way I'm just gonna keep going and I
guess the wind was right and you know
and you know it was like about you know
three weeks yeah which that's not a
that's not a [ __ ] that's not that
long yeah you can have it three weeks
worth of water and [ __ ] three weeks
where the food yeah cover yourself up
with a [ __ ] bike this sudden [ __ ]
burn you up out there on the oh yeah you
get X but you have intently he knew all
about that because people were Seafarer
deep righteous asked around what would
it take to get me there yeah some some
savings probably told him you better put
a [ __ ] roof on this yeah put a roof
on the boat yeah protip yeah it was like
a D that's pretty funny it's hardcore
yeah well like I said it's not like you
had much choice she can just hop down to
the airport and get on a little yeah
puddle jumpers who would that guy's name
was it go ahead and drop it in the
comments
I forgot what isn't it I don't think
that was Squanto it might have been
Squanto but I think it was another one
yeah come on Tom came back he did yeah
but I think he came on a merchant vessel
there was another guy who said [ __ ]
I'm going back and went back on his own
I don't have time to wait around I want
to go right now yeah yeah that's pretty
funny that's that's hilarious how you
went from talking about Mexican food and
now you're talking about Squanto
you told me come on possession we're
just trying to make an episode I was
trying to think of what else what did we
watch last night oh we watched um we're
gonna be reviewing it for those yeah for
the matinee show but we watched like a
new facade I may be called proximity
yeah it's pretty good where's actually
pretty good yeah it was like a real
throwback like eighties Close Encounters
meets romancing this noon nice thx let
me start it's it's it o majd George
Lucas stuff a lot oh yeah a lot and it
had a great to you but he had a great
classical score it was just like the
score from Star Wars yeah but then they
were throwing in rock music and [ __ ]
yeah I dug it yeah and the guy was
talking to aliens and
I had the force and then you know
spirituality was involved I don't want
to spoil it yeah cuz we're gonna do a
review of it for the that nation so I
don't want to talk too much about it but
you can rent it off an ex-boxer I think
for about five bucks yeah so it's
probably another VOD bro yeah what was
it called again proximity proximity yeah
go check it out and it's fun for the
whole family
yeah it's definitely a throwback like
80s family sci-fi divvy yeah adventure
if you're into like cosmic spirituality
and stuff you'd be into it but that's
kind of what Star Wars is about and
that's really what that's really kind of
what why I think it was omage and George
Lucas stuff a lot yeah because there is
kind of like the force in a way yeah
you'll see I think the next one we might
review and we probably could watch it
tonight is that samurai one yeah that
will probably do that samurai marathon
yeah the same guy it was Bernard Rose
the same guy that directed Candyman yeah
we're gonna show you original Candyman
and then what else we want before that
oh we watched him if you guys because I
know some of you guys like Dan Bell as
well and he has that show called another
dirty room where they stay in like
[ __ ] motels and for a night and like
everybody out dirty it is
I guess he recorded a whole bunch of
episodes like before the pandemic
because he did like a question and
answer like a live thing the other day
and he said he had like a whole bunch of
[ __ ] that he had filmed and hadn't
edited yet so I guess he's putting stuff
out because he's not going around and
staying anywhere and they did one last
night that was in New Orleans yeah
although that's it you know what the
place was gross but what is bad it
wasn't as bad as some of the other
places I mean they have I mean they have
everything they have like the heme test
they have like the blacklight they have
all the kind of [ __ ] for bedbugs looking
for bedbugs he's blood semen pee yeah
various other fluids so um I mean every
single I don't think I've ever seen I
think maybe one hotel they stayed in
because they rate them from one to five
I think I've seen one where they rated a
three where it's like it's not great but
we would stay here without being too
grossed out or like needing
- [ __ ] Silkwood shower afterward most
of them don't but most of them are a two
or a one at the moon and the thing about
it I mean the one they did last night
was $49 which I was like well at least
you're not paying because some of the
places that they seen him were worse
than that one and they were like eighty
ninety dollars and I'm like [ __ ] that
the worst one was the one outside of
Detroit remember that one was just a
zero they didn't want to be in there
yeah everything just roaches all over
the [ __ ] place yeah the place was
like German cockroaches was like below
crack hotel
I think the creepiest one I don't know
if it was the same one but the creepiest
one where they did where they did the
what do you call it the luminol yeah and
there were legit bloody handprints yeah
on the floor like a kid's bloody
handprints yeah so I'm like someone got
murdered in this room or something
I think so a lot of that blood is people
shooting up all the veins of [ __ ] sprays
out yeah yeah it's just like little
sprays and stuff but some of the stuff
it's like a lot like an getting blood on
her hands yeah I mean some of it might
be like the one that they did last night
they found like a little bit of blood it
was weird it was black and it didn't
look like blood and then they were like
well do a heme test on that because
maybe it is blood and it was and then it
looked like really lit up like with the
luminol and everything that looked like
somebody had a nosebleed
well you what you do a lot of people
don't realize you can get a drop of
blood on your hand and do this yeah and
it disappears but then you can touch
your hand against the wall and you don't
see a handprint their blood but under
luminol you would yeah so the one that
they the one that they found like that
was really alarming was a lot of blood
yeah I mean it was like streaks of blood
and handprint it looked like a kid was
crawling through like a puddle I didn't
see that so I was like someone either
got their ass kicked or got murdered
kids ass or something or or the kids mom
or something like that because a lot of
these are [ __ ] I mean in pretty much
every hotel room they find some kind of
drug paraphernalia in one they found a
plastic bag full of used underwear
like use panties so their head coach
else hooker hotels that's what they're
so I mean and that I think that's why
they stay in them like cuz it's much
funnier yeah like to just watch that I
mean they're looking for them they're
disgusting to watch I mean it's
disgusting well they show the reviews
but there's money but they're funny is
how they show the online reviews before
they even go there or like you know
people going by this is disgusting this
is what we're gonna go do yeah I think
that's why they do well because that's
like much funnier because they just go
in with their like which is [ __ ] tons
of beer and pot and everything like that
and they sit in there for apparently
because I've seen they did live once for
a while so they sit in there for like
four or five hours and film you know and
then later they'll edit it down to like
45 minutes or an hour or whatever but
they're super fun but it's not for the
squeamish because a few times I've been
watching that and been like oh yeah so
you want to wrap up the Monday grab that
[ __ ] up somebody said that we should
have any that says wrap that [ __ ] up
with it can I take a picture of you
doing do the gesture wrap it [ __ ] up
yeah like that so like this but then
like look kind of bad it's kind of like
that dude the [ __ ] you know like do
from seventeen hundred's is [ __ ]
point what's that guy's name I saw a
thing I hear do you look too cool as
[ __ ] like it's funny but that said that
is not who that dude was I said
everybody [ __ ] hated you hear who
that guy what he was really like but he
was like this absolutely ruthless
landlord [ __ ] chiseled his way
through other people he forced his
employees both male and female to sleep
with him or he [ __ ] would know fire
um chumming did all kinds of weird [ __ ]
- [ __ ] wives and women he died
because he [ __ ] drunk off his ass or
off a horse and I killed him and they
said and it's like written in the
[ __ ] local papers that he died and
that everyone was happy
yeah totally hated everybody hated him
can you imagine can you imagine in that
way that's why I kind of wish there was
an afterlife so people that were just
like complete dicks max in real life
like after they died
I wonder if they would be upset like
that everybody was like yay they're
finally [ __ ] dead no they or if
they'd just be like yeah that's more
yeah he's like yeah no they said he was
totally just like [ __ ] ruthless and
cruel and sardonic just laughter the
people suffering and loved the fact that
he was hated felt like I like a path
yeah [ __ ] psychopath I don't know why
I just thought of it I guess cuz you
were talking about that guy and he's
became like a meme yeah yeah but you
know when I was I was research in the
show when I was looking at pictures of
Eugen Sandow yeah and there's a meme
somebody made a meme out of him where
it's that one where he's laying down
like [ __ ] yeah thank you
and then somebody put on the top dust
thou even hoist yeah yeah yeah yeah that
is like I saw that I was gonna put it
this year but it's like I didn't but I
just thought you Jim was the [ __ ] man
that's that we even hoist yeah so you
guys have a good rest of your Monday
I'll talk to you guys again tomorrow